make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level series
we are going to be covering one of the
most formidable foes the Avengers have
ever faced michael korvac now of course
we did have a video on this character
being too powerful for the MCU but
unlike that we're gonna kind of go
through the various feats and the powers
that he has which is what we normally do
with the beyond Omega level or I guess
really the Omega beyond Omega level
series so michael korvac was created by
Steve Gerber in jim Starlin and first
appeared in giant-sized defenders number
three in 1975 originally envisioned as a
throw away villain by Steve Gerber the
character was later used as a villain
for the guardians of the galaxy and was
later the primary antagonist for an
Avengers event titled the korvac saga in
1978 under the writing of Jim shooter
and david michelinie now michael korvac
was born on the alternate reality earth
six nine one in the year twenty nine
seventy seven thirty years before earth
and the entire solar system was
conquered by the badoon now korvac is a
computer technician that betrays the
human race and begins working with the
bidder but once they catch him asleep on
the job
he's punished by being merged with a
machine which basically turns him into a
cyborg now he finds himself being
transported by the Grandmaster to battle
the defenders and he actually loses the
fight on purpose so that he can learn
the secrets of the grandmasters powers
and due to his Bionic Anatomy he's able
to gain a great deal of power kill has
been doing overlords and set off on a
quest to conquer the galaxy now later he
arrives in the main Marvel Universe also
known as earth-616 and happens upon the
space station belonging to Galactus and
so korvac ends up downloading the
knowledge that's contained within the
space station and in doing so absorbs
the power cosmic granting empowers
vastly more potent than what he had
already possessed and so as for what
powers Corvette possesses just by virtue
of being half human and half computer
he's able to absorb knowledge and energy
from electronic sources and then turn
that energy into techno beams that he
can use offensively against his
opponents he can also manipulate energy
and actually siphon energy from the
Grandmaster which allowed him to
teleport not only through space but time
as well now on one occasion
corvax manipulation of the time stream
to set up a meeting with a woman known
as Jena Drake ended up dismantling the
timeline of Earth 691 so that he could
rebuild the universe in a way that he
thought would be perfect with himself as
ruler not only that he's also able to
process information at extremely
fast speeds due to the fact that he is
effectively a living computer being able
to anticipate the types of spells that
dr. strange would used before they
actually left his fingertips and
calculating the correct defense
instantaneously
now korvac is also a being of advanced
intelligence and is extremely adept at
mechanical engineering having
constructed a fortress called wonder
world that housed the power siphon which
produced beams capable of causing sons
to go Nova and absorbing the power
generated by the resulting explosion now
one score vac is imbued with the power
cosmic on Galactus a Space Station his
powers are taken to a completely
different level now if you're not
familiar with what the power cosmic is
it's basically an endless source of
energy that grants incredible abilities
to those who wield it and the power
cosmic is really synonymous with
Galactus it's the power that he uses all
the time and it makes him immensely
powerful and it's what he also uses to
make his heralds powerful as well and so
the list of the powers of the power
cosmic grants to its users is basically
limitless and includes matter and energy
manipulation size alteration powerful
energy blasts and astral projection now
basically once Michael Kovak becomes
imbued with the power cosmic his power
is on scale with other cosmic beings and
he becomes practically godlike and his
abilities meaning he can pretty much
produce any effect he desires and so
when we look at michael korvac what we
end up seeing is that he was able to use
the power cosmic to do some really
impressive things an Avengers issue
number 175 as part of the korvac saga
he's referred to as a new-made god and
says that he was able to change the
fabric of reality eventually being able
to take control of it as long as he
concealed his presence from other near
omnipotent being now the use of the word
other here implies of course that korvac
himself is nearly omnipotent also the
collector one of the elders of the
universe remarks that korvac is more
dangerous than Thanos and that a war
with him would obliterate all of reality
Corvette is even referred to as a
universal threat which puts him well
into the beyond Omega level category now
Michaels energy blasts were powerful
enough to kill the collector with one
shot and to destroy a massive space
station from thousands of miles away now
in a battle with the Avengers he lays
waste to pretty much the entire roster
and is able to kill yellowjacket hawkeye
Carol Danvers Marvel Scarlet Witch Black
Panther Black Widow wasp
and Wonder Man during this whole thing
Silver Surfer remarks that Michaels
cosmic
could destroy entire worlds but after
boasting that Corvette would be
powerless against him Corvette melts the
silver coating off of the silver surfer
who himself possesses the power cosmic
as well and so being able to do this is
a crazy Display of power on another
occasion Michael corbat created a
forcefield that stood up to an attack
from the Red Skull wielding a cosmic
cube an extremely powerful object that's
capable of altering reality itself
korvac has matched Silver Surfer in
terms of strength and casually stopped a
strike from Thor with one hand and in
fact his strength was so immense that he
was able to rip Starhawk apart creating
a cataclysm that sent ripples throughout
the entire space-time continuum now
Corvette has also displayed the ability
to manipulate both matter and reality
he's able to create objects out of thin
air and was able to restore Starhawk to
life after killing him remaking him
molecule by molecule but altering his
mind so that he would have no
recollection of Corvus existence and
would not be able to perceive him in any
way
and so before korvac ends up ending his
own life he restores the lives of all
the heroes that he had slain and undid
all the damage that he had inflicted and
even though core vac did have some
limitations to his power for instance
ending his own life to avoid being
erased from existence by the ultimate
nullifier and being disintegrated and
having his atom scattered across
multiple dimensions by an antimatter
shot for the red skull empowered by the
Cosmic Cube he's still a being of
immense power and in fact eventually
recovered from both of those incidents
and as a god-like being that poses a
universal threat we can safely place
michael korvac at beyond omega level but
would that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained wish you
guys did the sub button to become part
of the rod core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]